The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to this
lecture on nonlinear finite
element analysis of solids and
structures.
In this lecture I would like
to discuss with you the
updated Lagrangian formulation
for general incremental
nonlinear analysis.
However, before doing so, I
thought it would be good to
take a bit of time and review
some of the material that we
have been discussing already.
We have been encountering
a large number of quite
complicated equations, some very
important basic concepts,
and some subtleties.
And to really understand all
of this material, it is
necessary to study it, of
course, a lot more than the
time that we have allocated
so far.
But it might help you to just
review now some of that
material once more.
I've prepared here on the marker
board the material that
relates to the total Lagrangian
formulation, in
which really you have been
seeing some of the very
important equations.
And here we have the basic
equation that is used, of
course, in finite element
analysis.
This basic equation states, of
course, it is the equation of
the principle of virtual work,
states that an internal
virtual work, or the internal
virtual work, must be equal to
external virtual work.
You remember that we talked
about the Cauchy stress, the
stress which is actually
force per unit area.
And that's the engineering
stress, that's the stress that
we want to solve for.
That we talked about
a virtual strain.
A virtual strain that
is referred to time
t plus delta t.
And that is why we have
this subscript here,
t plus delta t.
And we integrate this product
here over the volume at time t
plus delta t.
Notice that I'm using here a
green color for the real
stress that we want to solve
for, and a red color for the
virtual quantity that we're
using basically as a mechanism
to solve for this stress.
Of course, on the right-hand
side, we identified we have
the external virtual work.
And in here, this script R here,
denotes contributions
from the surface forces, body
forces that are being applied
externally to the body.
This is really the basic
equation that we want to
operate on, and that we want to
work with to solve for the
unknown Cauchy stresses at
time t plus delta t.
Now we recall, of course, that
we are here integrating over a
volume at time t plus delta t,
and that volume is unknown.
Because it is unknown, we cannot
very easily deal with
this stress measure, and we
have, therefore, introduced a
new stress measure.
A stress measure that we call
the second Piola-Kirchhoff
stress tensor.
We introduce this one here.
Notice this is a stress at time
t plus delta t, referred
to the original configuration,
0, of the body.
The capital S, and we have ij
as the components of that
stress tensor.
Now, this is a new stress tensor
that we know we can
deal very well with.
And we have to also introduce
a new strain tensor.
Why do we have to do so?
Well because using this stress
tensor, we have to use an
energy conjugate
strain measure.
And this Green-Lagrange strain
tensor, the Green-Lagrange
strain tensor is energy
conjugate to the second
Piola-Kirchhoff stress tensor.
Having introduced these two
quantities, and we looked at
the components, how they're
constructed, how they're
related, for example, in this
case, how this one is related
to the Cauchy stress.
Having now introduced these
two quantities, we can
directly work basically with
this equation here.
Well to do so, we have
decomposed the stress tensor
into a part that we know, and
into an unknown part.
And that's an important point.
We can decompose this stress
tensor into a stress that we
know, and that we don't know,
by simple addition
here on this side.
Notice we simply add here
because we had a quantity that
is referred to the volume at
time 0, to another quantity
that is referred to the
volume at time 0.
In other words, the reference
configurations for both of
these are the same, and that's
why we can have a simple
addition sign here.
Please keep in mind that this
quantity is known in our
incremental solution.
Because we, of course, assume
that we have solved for the
configuration of the body
up to a time t.
This one is unknown, and this is
the reason why I used here
black color to show that this
is an unknown quantity and
distinguish it from the
one that is known.
We proceed in the same
way with the
Green-Lagrange strain tensor.
Here we have the equations.
The Green-Lagrange strain tensor
at time t plus delta t
is decomposed into a quantity
that we know,
plus an unknown quantity.
Once again, in black.
So these are the two quantities
that we really want
to solve for, the increment in
the second Piola-Kirchhoff
stress, and the increment in
the Green-Lagrange strain.
Now we also discussed that
the increment in the
Green-Lagrange strain can
actually be decomposed into
two quantities.
One that is linear in the
particle incremental
displacements ui, and one that
is nonlinear in the particle
incremental displacements ui.
Please read it as follows.
Linear in ui, nonlinear in ui.
Of course, remember that we have
so far only spoken about
the continuum mechanics.
In other words, we have not
really, at this point, said
anything about the finite
element discretization.
We also referred, however, in an
earlier lecture to the fact
that if we do interpolate in
finite element analysis, then
using continuum elements for
the analysis of solids and
structures, the incremental
nodal point variables are
linearly related to these
incremental particle
displacements.
And for that reason, this is a
true linear strain increment,
and that is a true nonlinear
strain increment.
On the other hand, if we use
structural elements that also
include or use nodal point
rotations, then the particle
displacements, these ui's, are
linearly related to the
incremental nodal point
displacements, but nonlinearly
related to the incremental
nodal point rotations.
And in that case, this is here
still the true linear
increment of the Green-Lagrange
strain for the particle.
But this one here is not
containing all the nonlinear
strain incremental parts
for the particle.
There has to be a little bit--
there has to be some amendment
here, some addition here.
And we briefly talked about the
effect of neglecting this
addition as well.
Well the point now is that we
want to use, of course, these
two quantities to substitute
these into the equation of the
principle of virtual work, and
we then arrive directly at
this relationship here.
Now what do we see here?
We see an integral over the
original volume of the second
Piola-Kirchhoff stress referred
to the original
configuration, and it's a real
stress, the one that we want
to solve for, and that's why I
use the color green again.
This here is a virtual strain,
Green-Lagrange strain.
It's a variation on this
Green-Lagrange strain here.
And this product is integrated
over the original volume,
which is, of course, the
volume that we know.
And this is the reason
why we can so well
deal with this integral.
On the right-hand side, we have
made no modification.
We still have simply the
external virtual work.
Now, please realize that this
equation here is totally
equivalent to the equation that
we discussed earlier.
This equation here.
Here we are talking about
Cauchy stresses, an
infinitesimal virtual strain
integrated over a volume of
time t plus delta t
that is unknown.
This equation has simply been
re-cast into a new form using
continuum mechanics.
No finite elements really, just
continuum mechanics, into
this form here.
And now we have a form that we
can work very well with.
We substitute into this equation
and we linearize, and
we did that in the
earlier lecture.
The result of that substitution
and linearization
is given right here.
Now notice that in each of these
integrals, of course, we
are integrating over a
volume that is known,
the original volume.
Notice that in the first
integral here, we involve,
well a material tensor.
That has to be defined, it
depends on the material that
you're looking at, that
you want to analyze.
This is here the increment in
the Green-Lagrange strain, the
linear part only.
Here is a variation on this
linear increment in green--
sorry, it's in red, of course.
This one was green.
This one is in red.
And this is, of course,
a virtual quantity.
This is the virtual quantity.
Notice that here we are
talking about a
stress that we know.
We're incrementally
decomposing.
Remember?
We're adding to the quantities
at time t, the increment.
The quantities at time
t are known.
So this one is known.
This one here is a variation on
the nonlinear increment of
the Green-Lagrange strain,
total increment.
Well, in red again.
And on the right-hand side we
have the external virtual
work, which of course, is
assumed to be given.
Do you still remember that we
are talking about deformation
independent loading.
So we can calculate this
piece here directly.
And here we have also the stress
that is known, the
stress at time t, and the
virtual strain, linear strain.
This is what we arrived at
in our earlier lecture.
Of course, there was a
linearization involved, and we
know there would be errors
if we simply
operate on this equation.
We don't want to have these
errors in the actual finite
element solution.
And we realize that it
is good to iterate.
So we also looked in the earlier
lecture how we would
iterate typically.
And we developed an equation
where there was something on
the left-hand side, which I
simply denote here by dots.
There were quite some
complicated expressions.
You may want to look
them up again.
But I just denote them by dots
because what is really
important, and that I pointed
out also earlier, is what is
on the right-hand side.
And what do we see on
the right-hand side?
On the right-hand side we see
the external virtual work, and
we are subtracting from
it this integral.
Let's look at this integral
once more.
We have here the second
Piola-Kirchhoff stress at time
t plus delta t.
Of course, always refer to the
original configuration.
Corresponding to iteration
k minus 1.
The iteration here
written in black.
We are operating on the
Green-Lagrange strain at time
t plus delta t.
Refer to the original
configuration in
iteration k minus 1.
Actually, calculated at the end
of iteration k minus 1 is
better to say.
And this product here is
integrated over the original
volume once more.
k runs from 1, 2, 3, onwards.
Well notice that when k is equal
to 1 we have a 0 here,
and we have to ask ourselves
what is this quantity then?
Well if there's a 0 right here,
then we're looking here
at t 0 Sij.
The stress, the second
Piola-Kirchhoff stress
corresponding to the
configuration at time t.
And if we put a 0 here, we
would have also here, the
initial condition being the
Green-Lagrange strain at time
t, of course, referred
to configuration 0.
So we have the write initial
conditions here, and therefore
we can proceed with
the iteration.
We discussed that in the
earlier lecture.
The important point now is
that once this iteration
converges, we have to use, of
course, schemes, solution
procedures that makes the
iteration converge.
We will talk about that
in later lecture.
But once we have obtained
convergence, and let's assume
we have converged, then this R,
the script R, the external
virtual work, is equal
to this integral.
That's how we define
convergence.
And this means then that the
external virtual work is now
equal to the internal
virtual work.
What does this mean?
It means in essence, that this
right-hand side is 0, which
means-- and now I like to go
back to our earlier equation--
that this equation here is
satisfied because notice that
if you look at this equation
and you take this left-hand
side and bring it to the
right-hand side with a minus
in front, then you have
exactly what we
just looked at earlier.
In other words, our iteration
is performed really on an
expression that is nothing else
than this R, this script
R, minus this one on the
right-hand side.
There's a minus sign here and
you take this and bring it
right there.
That's what we just looked at.
Of course, we also remember now
that this expression now
is really totally equivalent
to what we started with.
Namely, this expression
right here.
And this is, of course, what
we really want a solve.
We mentioned earlier that
we introduced the second
Piola-Kirchhoff stress, and that
we would like to get a
physical understanding possibly
of that stress.
And I mentioned that that is
very difficult to obtain.
In the computer program, we
just work with that stress
measure in order to be able to
solve the equation, to operate
well on the principle
of virtual work.
What we really want to do, of
course, is to solve this
equation right here.
This is the equation.
That is the physical stress
that we want to solve for.
Well since this equation is
totally equivalent to that
equation, and looking at this
equation, if we take this
left-hand side, bring it to
the right-hand side--
of course, there's a minus
appearing there--
we do obtain what we see right
here at convergence of course.
We operate properly on the
principle of virtual work.
So this really closes, so to
say, the loop, and I hope it
helps you to have this overview
in understanding of
what I discussed earlier
with you.
But let's go one step further.
In the finite element
discretization, we obtain from
this equation here--
I haven't listed what is on the
left-hand side, you can
look it up--
we obtain directly this
equation here.
Of course, there's quite a
number of steps that we still
have to discuss.
How we obtain this matrix,
we call this the tangent
stiffness matrix.
We have to discuss how we
calculate this vector here,
this vector here.
In fact, the way we actually
introduced it, since it's a
total Lagrangian formulation, I
should really put here a 0.
We have to discuss how we can
calculate this vector for
different elements, et cetera,
and there is a
lot still to be learned.
But remember that up to here, we
only talked about continuum
mechanics, and this is where
the finite element
discretization starts.
And these are then the basic
equations that are being
arrived at.
At convergence, once again, here
we iterate, of course.
Notice that I'm using now
the superscript i.
Of course, this superscript is
a dummy, it could be k, it
could be j, it doesn't matter.
We frequently use i.
I didn't want to use up here i
because we have an i already
as a subscript, that's
why I'm using k here.
But at convergence in this
iteration where we calculate
always new displacements, add
them to the previously
calculated displacements, at
convergence the right-hand
side will be 0, or close
to 0, of course.
Well this means that we arrive
at this equation right here.
Because when the right-hand side
is 0, we satisfy that t
plus delta t R is equal to t
plus delta t F And if you
like, here also, we may want
to introduce this little 0,
signifying that we have used
the total Lagrangian
formulation to calculate
that F.
Now it is important to realize
what we have achieved in the
finite element solution.
We satisfy compatibility in the
finite element solution if
we use compatible
finite elements.
That is buried in here.
We use compatible finite
elements to calculate this F,
therefore we satisfy
compatibility.
We satisfy the stress strain law
properly if we calculate
this F here accurately and
properly through the stress
strain law.
Of course, there is much
to be discussed still.
But let's assume we do that
properly and then we satisfy
the stress strain law.
Equilibrium we also satisfy,
but at the nodal points.
We talked about the fact, in an
earlier lecture, that in a
finite element analysis,
displacement based finite
element analysis, we always
satisfy equilibrium at the
nodal point.
Of course, assuming that the
elements have been properly
formulated.
We would only satisfy local
equilibrium if the mesh is
fine enough.
And we talked earlier, in an
earlier lecture, about how we
can measure whether local
equilibrium is well enough
satisfied using stress jumps,
using pressure band plots.
We talked about that and I
gave you some examples.
The important point though is to
recognize that if we use a
fine enough mesh, then
equilibrium is satisfied, and
the stress strain law would be
satisfied if we calculated
stresses properly from
the given strains.
And compatibility is satisfied
if we use a compatible finite
element mesh.
In other words, the three basic
important requirements
of mechanics are fulfilled when
we are satisfying this
relationship right here.
This basically then rounds
up what we have been
discussing so far.
And we use the total Lagrangian
formulation in this
discussion.
I now like to go over to discuss
this, use the updated
Lagrangian formulation.
The interesting point here is
that we use a stress measure
that is referred to the original
configuration, and so
a strain measure that is
referred to the original
configuration.
I mentioned earlier already that
we want to deal with a
certain configuration
that is known.
The reason, of course, being
that we want to incrementally
decompose this stress into a
quantity that we know, plus a
quantity that we don't know.
And that incremental
decomposition should involve
stress measures that are
referred to a configuration
that is known.
The same for the strains.
Well since we have calculated
all the configurations from
time 0 to time t already, a
natural question to ask is why
don't you use a configuration
other than 0, say, the
configuration at time delta
t to delta t, or t.
well in the updated Lagrangian
formulation, we, indeed, use
the configuration at time t as
a reference configuration.
And so we deal then with the
second Piola-Kirchhoff stress
referred to the configuration
at time t.
This is the stress that
we're dealing with.
Notice t plus delta t here,
still the stress at time t
plus delta t, but now the stress
is referred to the
configuration at time t.
Similarly, we also deal
with a strain.
The Green-Lagrange strain at
time t plus delta t, but
referred to configuration
at time t.
We could, of course,
ask, well why use a
configuration at time t?
Why not use some configuration
in between?
The answer is, and I gave it to
you already in an earlier
lecture, the answer is that
you are losing all of the
advantages of the total
Lagrangian formulation, and
you're losing the advantages
of the updated Lagrangian
formulation.
You are left only with
the disadvantages.
So there's very little point
really in trying to solve the
principle of virtual work using
another configuration
other than 0 or t.
Let us now look at the details
of the updated Lagrangian
formulation.
And here I have now prepared
some view graphs that show all
the equations that we're
operating on.
The principle of virtual work,
once again, is given right on
this first view graph.
We always start with the basic
principle of virtual work, and
that is written here.
This is, once again, the Cauchy
stress, the stress that
we are actually interested
in solving for.
This is the infinitesimal
virtual strain.
Internal virtual work is equal
to external virtual work.
Now, with the stress measure
that I just mentioned to you,
and the corresponding strain
measure, substituted for these
stress and strain measures, we
obtain directly this equation.
Notice that here on the
left-hand side, we have an
integral that is exactly equal
to this integral here.
And that we are not
talking here about
finite elements yet.
It's all continuum mechanics
at this point.
The second Piola-Kirchhoff
stress here refer to time t
is, of course, defined as the
same way as the second
Piola-Kirchhoff stress
as before when it was
referred to time 0.
But what we have to do now is
introduce this t whenever we
use the 0 before in the equation
linking up the Cauchy
stress with the second
Piola-Kirchhoff stress.
We already then know the
solution at time t.
So we know basically these
quantities here.
And we can, therefore, now
decompose directly the
stresses into a stress that
we know, and an increment.
Similarly, we do for
the strains.
It's now interesting to observe
that this stress here
is nothing else than
the Cauchy stress.
If you were to plug in to the
formula that I gave you
earlier, which once again,
expresses the second
Piola-Kirchhoff stress in terms
of the Cauchy stress,
you would simply see that this
quantity is nothing else than
the Cauchy stress.
And therefore, we have
that now here.
And of course, we carry this
part in that equation here.
The Green-Lagrange strain, if
written out, one directly
identifies that this part here
is 0, because we are using
only the increments in
displacements from time t to
time t plus delta t.
And we are left with this part
here, which is unknown.
Let's look at the Green-Lagrange
strain here.
Notice t plus delta
t, t epsilon ij is
written as shown here.
Where I should point out that
we are looking here at the
displacements from time t
to time t plus delta t.
In other words, if I want to
write this out here, I'm doing
it as follows.
I'm saying that it's a partial
of the displacements, t plus
delta t, ui minus tui
with respect to txj.
Notice that here, we are
subtracting from the
displacement at time
t plus delta t, the
displacements tui.
So it's the incremental
displacements that we're
dealing with.
And we're differentiating with
respect to the coordinate at
the time t.
Similarly, of course, we define
these expressions here,
and those expressions, and
those expressions.
Notice, just to emphasize this
point, that this here is
nothing else than ui.
And if we now substitute from
here into there, we directly
recognize that this term is, in
fact, the same as that one,
which I expressed already on
the earlier view graph.
Notice, linear part here,
nonlinear part there.
This part here, of course,
I like to just write out
for you once more.
It's nothing else than partial
ui with respect to txj.
Notice, here we have a product
incremental displacement, and
that's why it is, of
course, nonlinear.
It is interesting to compare
this expression for the
Green-Lagrange strain, for the
incremental Green-Lagrange
strain, to the incremental
Green-Lagrange strain of the
total Lagrangian formulation.
And if you do so, you'll find
that the major difference is
that in the total Lagrangian
formulation you have an
initial displacement effect.
Here, we do not have an initial
displacement effect.
And in fact, that is one of the
advantages of the updated
Lagrangian formulation.
We can now define, just as
in the total Lagrangian
formulation, a linear strain
increment, and a nonlinear
strain increment.
Of course, linear in the
incremental displacement of
the particles.
Nonlinear in the incremental
displacement of the particles.
And this means that
directly we obtain
this expression here.
And the variation on here,
of course, on this total
Green-Lagrange strain increment
is simply given by
these two additions.
The equation of the principle
of virtual work now becomes
substituting from what I just
discussed with you, directly
this equation.
Notice we have here now, the
external virtual work, just as
before, and we have here the
internal virtual work
corresponding to the
stresses at time t.
And these are actually
the Cauchy
stresses, the real stresses.
This is here again our
out of balance
virtual work, so to say.
On the left-hand side, we have
one part that includes an
increment in the stress.
Refer to time t now, because
the t configuration is our
reference configuration.
And we are multiplying it by
the variation on the total
Green-Lagrange strain
increment--
that's one integral--
over the volume at time t.
And here we have the Cauchy
stress times the variation on
the nonlinear part of the
Green-Lagrange strain increment.
Given a variation in
displacement data ui, of
course, we can calculate
the right-hand side.
But we recognize that on the
left-hand side, we have
unknown displacement increments
and there would be
nonlinearities occurring
on the left-hand side.
Remember, that so far no
approximations have been made.
This is a statement that is
valid for any amount of
deformation, any amount
of displacements,
rotations, and strains.
Just as in the total Lagrangian
formulation, the
equation of the principle of
virtual work in the updated
Lagrangian formulation is, of
course, a very complicated
equation and highly nonlinear
in the incremental
displacement.
And we somehow have
to linearize.
Because we want to obtain a
finite element solution, we
linearize first the principle of
virtual work equation, and
then we are ready to obtain an
equation as shown here, which
is very much like the equation
which we are operating on
using the total Lagrangian
formulation.
Notice, because we're dealing
with the updated Lagrangian
formulation, we now have a t
here, and we have a t there,
meaning the reference
configuration is the time t
configuration, and
here as well.
We begin to linearize the terms
just as we have done it
earlier in the total Lagrangian
formulation.
And we recognize that
this term here is
already linear in ui.
That is quite simply seen
because the stress does not
contain ui, it's a
known quantity.
The variation on this part here
gives us this expression.
And we recognize that this is
linear in ui because here we
have the unknown ui appearing.
This is going to be a constant
for a given variation in
displacement.
And this is here also
linear and ui.
This is going to be a constant
for a given variation in
displacement.
And so we have a linear
part here in ui.
No linearization
required here.
Let us now look at
the next term.
Here we have the increment in
the second Piola-Kirchhoff
stress times the variation
on the increment in the
Green-Lagrange strain
integrated over the
volume at time t.
We recognize that tSij is a
nonlinear function in general
of the increment in the
Green-Lagrange strain.
If we take the variation
on that increment and
Green-Lagrange strain, we obtain
these two terms, and we
recognize that this is also
a linear function of ui.
Therefore, in this product, we
have to neglect now all higher
order terms in ui.
First we recognize now that
tSij can be written as a
Taylor series expansion,
as shown here.
Notice that tSij is equal to
one first term plus higher
order terms.
These higher order
terms we neglect.
If you look at this term here,
we recognize that we can
substitute for this term,
as shown here.
And this one here is, of course,
the constitutive
relation, the tangent
constitutive
relation for the material.
Recognizing that this one here
is quadratic in ui, we drop
that term and we get this
linearized result.
Notice that here we have a
constitutive tensor referred
to the configuration
at time t.
In the total Lagrangian
formulation we had here a 0
instead of a t.
Well if we now look at the
product that we wanted to
linearize again, we have this
product on the left-hand side,
which is now approximately
equal to this term here.
This already we derived as a
linearization to that term.
Here we are substituting
for that term here.
Notice that if we multiply out,
we directly obtain this
relationship here.
This one here does not
contain ui of course.
And this one here
is linear in ui.
This means that since this one
also is linear in ui, that we
have here a quadratic
term in ui.
Notice this term now, totally
linear, this one quadratic, we
drop that one, and we are left
with the linearized result,
the result that we
wanted to obtain.
The final linearized equation
is then given
on this view graph.
Notice we have here the
constitutive relation times
the linear strain increment in
the total Green-Lagrange
strain increment, the
variation on it.
And of course, this one again
integrated over the
volume at time t.
Here we have a term
where there was no
linearization necessary.
And here we have a term
also there was no
linearization necessary.
These two terms were obtained
already earlier.
These here, this term be
obtained by linearization.
Notice that when we now use
finite element interpolations,
we will express this total term
here via this term here
where we now have a tangent
finite element matrix, which
is denoted by the t up there
at time t referred to the
configuration at time t.
This t here refers to the
There's an increment in the
displacement that we want to
solve for, the real displacement
increment.
And this is here, the virtual
displacement vector.
The right-hand side gives us a
virtual displacement vector,
of course, transposed times this
vector, and here we have
the externally applied loads
coming from the external
virtual work minus the nodal
point force vector
corresponding to the internal
element stresses.
That is this term here results
into this nodal point force
vector corresponding to the
internal element stresses.
So here we have the continuum
mechanics relation in black,
linearized from the general
principle of virtual work, and
here we have the finite element
expression of that.
Of course, the actual finite
element solution is then
obtained by actually setting
this vector here equal to the
identity matrix so that we are
left with K times delta U is
equal to t plus delta
tR minus tF.
An important point in this
development is to recognize
that this term here is, of
course, the virtual work due
to the element internal
stresses at time t.
And we interpret this part here
as the out of balance
virtual work just in the same
way as we have been doing it
in the total Lagrangian
formulation.
Let's look now at the total
solution using the updated
Lagrangian formulation.
The displacement iteration is
much the same way as in the
total Lagrangian formulation.
We take the old value
corresponding to k minus 1
iteration, and add an increment
that we are solving
for to obtain a new estimate
on the displacements.
k being the iteration counter.
Notice, of course, in this
iteration, we have to have
initial conditions, and these
initial conditions are given
right here.
In other words, when k is equal
to 1, we would have here
t plus delta t ui 0, and
therefore we need this value,
and that value is given right
here as t plus delta tui, 0
equal to tui.
In other words, the displacement
at the
configuration t.
If you look now at the total
continuum mechanics equations
that we are operating on, I
should say one continuum
mechanics equation really,
which, of course, gives us
then in the finite element
discretization, the set of
simultaneous equations that
we will be working with.
This continuum mechanics
equation looks as follows.
On the left-hand side we have
the tangent constitutive
relationship times an increment
in real strains that
we want to solve for
in iteration k.
These are the virtual strains.
We integrate that product over
the volume at time t.
That, of course, holds for any
one of these integrals.
And here we have now the actual
stresses, the real
stresses that we know already,
which correspond to the
configuration at time t.
Then a variation on the
incremental Green-Lagrange
strain, but I should add its
only the nonlinear increment
in the Green-Lagrange strain
corresponding to iteration k.
Once again, integrated over
the volume at time t.
And on the right-hand side, we
have the external virtual work
and this expression.
Let's look at this expression
carefully.
Here we have an integral over
the volume at time t plus
delta t in the iteration
k minus 1.
Therefore, we are updating that
volume as we go along in
the iteration.
Notice that here we have the
stresses corresponding to
iteration k minus 1.
We are updating these stresses,
of course, also in
the iteration.
Here we have the virtual strains
corresponding to
iteration at the end of
iteration k minus 1.
We are updating this as well.
And this product here, once
again, is integrated over the
volume at time t plus delta t
corresponding to the end of
iteration k minus 1 or the
beginning of iteration k.
Well it's important to realize
that when this right-hand side
is 0, we have fulfilled, or we
have basically solved, the
equation of the principle of
virtual work, because the
external virtual work is equal
to the internal virtual work.
And then, of course, we have
obtained the solution.
So we iterate with k equals 1,
2, 3, and so on, until the
right-hand side is 0, and then
we are satisfying that the
external virtual work is equal
to the internal virtual work.
When we discretize this
continuum mechanics equation
via finite elements, we obtain
this equation here.
ttK, once again, the tangent
stiffness matrix.
Here, the increment in the
nodal point displacements
corresponding to iteration k.
On the right-hand side
the R vector of
externally applied loads.
And here, the nodal point force
vector corresponding to
the internal element stresses
at time t plus delta t in
iteration k minus 1.
At the end of iteration
k minus 1 is
more precisely said.
Notice that we are having a t
plus delta t down here because
we are always updating
the actual
configuration of reference.
Here we are updating the
configuration of reference
because we are working with the
Cauchy stresses at time t
plus delta t, and in iteration
at the end of
iteration k minus 1.
Of course, this vector is
calculated from the
displacement at time
t plus delta t, and
iteration k minus 1.
These, of course, are known.
This is a known quantity,
whereas the unknown quantity
are the increments in
the displacements.
These we want to calculate.
We iterate until, with k equals
1, 2, 3, and so on,
until the right-hand
side is 0.
Of course, this is nothing else
than an expression of, in
finite element analysis, of the
principle of virtual work
where we had also the right-hand
side, this was the
external virtual work, and this
was the internal virtual
work corresponding to the
current element stresses.
Notice that the displacements
that we are talking about here
are obtained by adding all the
incremental displacement that
we're dealing with here.
We are taking these and add them
all up as expressed in
this summation sign here. j goes
from 1 to k to get, and
we take that sum, of course,
and add it to tU, the
displacement corresponding to
configuration time t, to get
the displacements
corresponding to the last iteration.
The total iterative process is
summarized on this view graph.
We start with a given tU, the
displacement at time t are
given, and the external loads
are also given corresponding
to time t plus delta t.
We compute the tangent stiffness
matrix corresponding
to time t, and the nodal point
force vector corresponding to
the internal element
stresses at time t.
This nodal point force vector
provides initial conditions
for this vector, because that is
the vector which will enter
actually into the iteration.
This displacement vector
provides the initial
conditions for that vector.
We set the iteration counter
k equal to 1.
We go in here, and notice now we
are solving this equation,
which we just discussed.
When k is equal to 1, of course,
we have here F0, and
that F0 is nothing else
than that vector here.
Because that's how we
initialized it.
So we can calculate
this incremental
displacement vector.
We add that increment and
displacement vector to the
displacement which
we had already.
When k is equal to 1, of course,
this vector here is
nothing else than that vector,
which we are given already.
We add on and get a new
estimate for the
displacements.
We then check for convergence.
This means we are checking
whether equilibrium is
satisfied sufficiently, meaning
whether the right-hand
side is 0 with this new
displacement estimate.
If we have not converged, we go
into the next calculation
of the force vector, the nodal
point force vector
corresponding to the current
internal element stresses.
And notice that, of course, now
this force vector, these
elements stresses that go in
here, are computed based on
the displacement at time t plus
delta t at the end of
iteration k.
In other words, these are the
displacements that we have
just been calculating
right there.
We increase the iteration
counter, and keep
on looping as before.
So this is the loop that we go
through in the iteration until
we converge, until
we converge.
If you compare this view graph
with the view graph that we
discussed in the total
Lagrangian formulation, you
will find a great similarity.
You will find that basically all
of these quantities have
already been discussed in the
total Lagrangian formulation,
except that in the total
Lagrangian formulation we
always carry it down here and
down there as 0 instead of t,
t plus delta t here.
We carry it as 0.
Well because the reference
configuration was the 0
configuration.
Now the reference configuration
for the
stiffness matrix is the
t configuration.
The reference configuration for
the F vector is the t plus
delta t configuration after
iteration k minus 1.
So there's a great similarity
in the iteration process, in
the finite element matrices
that we are setting up.
And of course, we have to ask
ourselves what comparison is
there between the T.L.
and U.L. formulation?
Why would one want to use the
U.L. formulation if we have
the T.L. formulation,
for example.
Well in the T.L. formulation,
all the derivatives are
defined with respect to the
original configuration.
In the U.L. formulation, they
are defined with respect to
the current configuration.
And that will provide
differences, that does provide
differences.
For example, in the U.L.
formulation, we will have to
calculate the derivatives
newly in each iteration,
because the configuration
is continuously updated.
We don't need to do it, of
course, for the k matrix if we
keep the k matrix constant
on the left-hand side.
But for the F vector on the
right-hand side, we will have
to always calculate new
derivatives because the F
vector involves the Cauchy
stresses times the
infinitesimal virtual strains
referred to the current
configuration, t plus delta t,
iteration k minus 1, which is
being updated.
And so we would always calculate
new derivatives
right there.
There, of course, is an
expense involved.
On the other hand, the U.L.
formulation does not have this
initial displacement effect that
I mentioned earlier, so
there's an advantage.
In the U.L. formulation,
we also directly
deal with Cauchy stresses.
These are, of course, the
physical stresses that we are
actually interested in, and that
we want to get printed
out from the computer program.
Hence, there's no transformation
necessary from
some stress measure, and I'm
thinking of the second
Piola-Kirchhoff stress that we
use in the total Lagrangian
formulation, to the Cauchy
stresses that we actually want
to obtain in the computer
program, and that we as
engineers want to get, of
course, printed out.
Well if we now look at one other
important point, one
important point, regarding the
T.L. and U.L. formulation, we
recognize that if we make
the assumption, the same
assumptions, in both of these
two formulations in the
linearization, as we, of course,
have done, really, the
way I've presented it.
Then the U.L. and T.L.
formulation, provided the
appropriate transformations
are made, certain
transformation rules are
followed for the stresses, the
strains, and so on.
Those rules we will be talking
about further later on in
later lectures.
Then, indeed, exactly the same
stiffness matrix and force
vector, F vector, vectors I
should say, are calculated.
In other words, provided we
follow certain transformation
rules, indeed, the same
stiffness matrices and force
vectors are calculated in both
of these formulations.
Of course, the actual numerical
arithmetic required
to obtain those matrices
and vectors
are, of course, different.
But the final result
is the same.
We can demonstrate that in the
general case, as I will do
later on in a lecture, and we
can also demonstrate that on
simple examples.
In fact, we will look in one
lecture at the truss element
where we can directly show
that the T.L. and U.L.
formulation really give exactly
the same result for
the k matrix, as well
as the F vector.
So there we have an example,
but as I mentioned, we can
also show it in the general
case, and that we do
as well later on.
Thank you very much for
your attention.